die sechste sache ich habe immense angst
vor
hahaha ich meine lieben freunde und
willkommen
seine frau in folge ich lasse es einfach
mal komplett mit der ukulele wenn ich
war aus willkommen zu einer neuen folge
luca erzählt durch irgendwelche dinge di
luca irgendwie mal erzählen möchte und
zwar meine damen und herren geht es
heute um das thema zehn dinge die ich
mich vor fürchte ich habe mir einfach
gedacht ich habe ja schon mal also
sachen gemacht so 10 dinge die ich mag
dinge die ich nicht mag und nicht das
waren 20 dinge aber das ging mir immer
zu lange deswegen bin ich jetzt auf zehn
dinge runter gegangen und ich habe mir
wirklich mal über eine woche überlegt
einerseits so kleine kleinigkeiten vor
denen ich einfach angst habe und auch so
sachen vor denen ich mich so ein
bisschen komplexer gedacht fürchte so
was in der zukunft oder was ich hoffe
ihr wisst was ich meine und ich fange
einfach mal an wenn ihr zu irgendeiner
sache sagt borer das ist voll peinlich
sich davor zu fürchten das brauchst du
gar nicht das hilft mir auch nicht
weiter das habe ich einfach weil sie
nicht das einfach mal meine
eigenschaften so dass ich davon dann
irgendwie angst habe oder irgendwie
sowas
ich weiß nicht vielleicht sind wir auch
überein könnt ihr mal bei jeder sache
und unten in die kommentare schreiben
habe ich auch davor fürchtet ob jemanden
kennt der damit schon mal erfahrung
gemacht hat oder irgendwie so will geht
respektvoll in den kommentaren
miteinander um und wir fangen direkt an
mit der ersten sachen erste sache ist
etwas was ich schon sehr oft in videos
gesagt habe und zwar nicht allgemein
spinnen aber allgemein insekten die über
mir sind also wenn ich jetzt auf dem
boden irgendwo eine spinne sehe ich eine
raupe oder ein wurm oder weiß ich dass
ich es überhaupt nicht schlimm aber wenn
beispielsweise ein kumpel sagt hey guck
mal hoch und nicht gekocht dann hält er
da so einen regenwurm oder so dann
kriegt die krise oder allgemein wenn ich
in einer dusche zum beispiel stand ich
letztens hey mein schreibtisch holz ist
ein bisschen gesplittert das zieht sich
auseinander was ist denn los damit
jedenfalls ich stand letztes in der
dusche auf einmal über mir passiert auf
einmal so eine spinne und ich hatte echt
ich war kurz vorm herzinfarkt also tiere
oder allgemein nicht jeder aber insekten
über mir sind die sich über meer
befinden kann ich gar nicht ab habe ich
extrem schiff war die zweite sache ist
etwas was eventuell nicht so viele von
euch beurteilen können und zwar auf der
autobahn wenn ich die linke spur fahrer
also ich denke jeder von euch ist
irgendwie schon mal mit papa oder mama
autobahn mit gefahren oder halt auch
selber autobahn gefahren
wenn man linke spur fährt oder mittlere
spur auf jeden fall alles außer rechte
spur
dann kann ich kann's halt am besten
zeigen wenn man stellt euch vor der
linken spur und dann überholt man ja die
ganzen autos sicher von mittleren und
rechten spur fahren und auch ver
mittleren spur
wenn dann da so fünf autos ganz nah
hintereinander fahren und halt den
sicherheitsabstand nicht einhalten dann
denke ich immer wenn ich an den
vorbeifahre verdammt nicht dass einer
jetzt ausschert und irgendwie anderen
überholen will oder so da denke ich mir
mal so ich war so dran vorbei so bleibt
da wo ihr seid kommt nicht rüber ich
habe tiere dann noch immer mit dem
blinker und sagt dann wenn ich auf der
linken spur wird und ich sehe da ist
eine karawane dienen wir vom mittleren
spur mache ich den linken blinker nach
links rein dass ich zeigen hey hallo ich
bin da nicht hier das nämlich rheinfahrt
weil wir hatten das schon mal als ich
damals mit meiner familie in urlaub
gefahren bin
wir linke spur kamen autori das war so
gar nicht mehr auf der autobahn das war
auf einer landstraße oder so da hatte
uns einer die vorfahrt genommen und
seitdem bin ich dann mal echt extrem
vorsichtig weil normalerweise ist ja
quasi genau das gleiche wie mit vorfahrt
gewähren wenn jemand auf der linken spur
ist und schnell fährt dann kannst du ihm
halt nicht einfach da vorfahren oder
irgendwie so alles weil du musst darfst
du ja nicht irgendwie bedrängend quasi
sage ich mal
deswegen ist das schon richtig mit
vorfahrt und so aber das ist auf jeden
fall aus dem moment wo ich immer so ein
bisschen angst habe also auf der
autobahn ich bin auf der linken spur
und da ist eine karawane und da hab ich
mal angst dass einer aus dritte sache
von der ich extrem angst habe ist dass
jemand der mir sehr nahe steht also
familienmitglieder oder sehr gute
freunde von mir sterben ich muss
wirklich sagen und ich glaube das hat
sich jetzt echt ein bisschen komisch an
aber ich habe mehr angst davor dass eine
person die ich seit jahren kenne die ich
extrem schätze und die mir sehr am
herzen liegt dass die stadt als also
dafür hab ich mehr angst als vor meinem
eigenen tod ich weiß nicht warum ich das
so empfinde und vielleicht empfinden ja
viele so aber ich habe mich da auch
bisher mit recht wenigen drüber
unterhalten aber ich finde einfach wenn
man selber tot ist dann ist man halt
dann weiß man nicht mehr wie sich so die
anderen anfühlen aber wenn jetzt
beispielsweise jemand stirbt aus meiner
familie dann weiß ich wirklich der kommt
nie wieder zurück und das ist für mich
etwas wovor ich sehr viel angst habe und
deswegen habe ich davor auch viel viel
mehr angst dass jemand plötzlich stirbt
auf einmal der mir sehr viel bedeutet
als von meinem eigenen tod die vierte
sache ist etwas was mir schon in der
jugend immer aufgefallen ist und zwar
immer irgendwie beim fußball irgendwie
pressschlag und beiden kaputt und ach
nee ich muss ich zum orthopäden oder ja
hier hingeflogen und übelst viel dreck
nach wunder passiert eh nix kommen wir
zusammen noch ein bisschen weiter und so
ich habe mich bei so wunden oder schiff
runden die ich hatte nie so wirklich um
die behandlungen gekümmert also sind
natürlich nur schürfwunden die tun dann
für den moment w 14 minuten danach ist
der schmerz wieder weg dann tun sie wenn
du tust und wird plötzlich alles aber
ich habe mich nie darum gekümmert da
dann irgendwie creme drauf zu packen
oder irgendwie sowas deswegen hab ich so
ein ganz klein bisschen angst davor dass
später irgendwann ich mega die
rückenschmerzen hat weil mein bein
wollen eine zeit lang kaputt war david
plötzlich oder irgendwie mal dass mir
mein finger abgibt oder so weil ich mich
da mal voll gerissen drin habe und dann
war da noch ganz viel dreck drinnen und
30 also ich hab halt damals nie so
darauf geachtet wurden wirklich
verheilen zu lassen deswegen glaube ich
dass man das später irgendwann zum
verhängnis wird und das ist die vierte
sache vor der ich mich so ein bisschen
fürchte die fünfte sache ist etwas was
ich mich in letzter zeit immer öfter
frage und zwar ob ich mein leben
wirklich richtig genießen also man lebt
ja nur einmal quasi so jolo mäßig und
deswegen sollte man es eigentlich nicht
damit verschwenden zu lernen und zu
arbeiten und weiß ich deswegen frage ich
mich in letzter zeit ob es das alles
wert ist ob mann ob youtube und und uni
und alles vereinbar ist und so zur zeit
klappt alles aber ich versuche mir da
immer zu sagen ja du machst alles
richtig aber irgendwie macht es dann
doch nicht richtig und keine ahnung das
ist halt auch so etwas wovor ich mich
ein bisschen fürchte so einfach diese
frage an mich selbst genießt du dein
leben eigentlich weil schnell noch vor
ihr lebt jeden tag ein tag mehr das
natürlich nicht viel oder jede minute
oder sowas aber man sollte eigentlich
echt alles genießen weil keiner kann
beraten wie es nach dem tod ist oder ob
man einfach wirklich weg ist oder
irgendwie so aber ich weiß nicht man
lebt halt quasi nur einmal deswegen
sollte man das ich genießen und das habe
ich halt so ein bisschen angst dass ich
das gerade nicht tue
die sechste sache ich habe immense angst
vorm fliegen das ist jetzt nicht erst
seit dem flugunglück von der a320
germanwings maschine dass ich angst vorm
fliegen habe sondern das habe ich ja
schon öfters mal gesagt einfach mit der
kontrolle bei fortbewegungsmittel nicht
fahre sehr gerne auto und extrem oft
auto also wenn ich mal irgendwie von
hamburg nach münchen muss oder wird
besser ich von bielefeld nach köln oder
irgendwohin
ich fahre echt immer mit dem auto oder
wenn ich mal von bielefeld nach berlin
muss wo es eventuell sogar einfacher
wäre zu fliegen fahre ich dann auch bahn
und so was alles bei wänden der bahn ein
defekt ist dann kannst halt bleibt die
bahn halt stehen und du steigst aus oder
wenn du im auto auf einmal wenn den
reifen platzt dann erhält sie halt an
oder wenn du keinen sprit mehr hast oder
wenn sonst irgendwas ist da hast du halt
so selbst quasi die macht
beziehungsweise diese kraft selbst etwas
zu bewirken allerdings wenn oben in den
zehn kilometern höhe die ein flugzeug
fliegt wenn da irgendwas passiert dann
kannst du nichts machen bei den german
wings absturz soll jetzt nicht mehr die
technik versagt haben sondern das soll
ja ein selbstmordattentat gewesen sein
von dem co-piloten ich bin mir nicht
sicher weil ich halt gerade
vorproduzieren bin weil ich am
wochenende flieger nach münchen
aber es kann immer mal passieren dass da
irgendwas ist und dann finde ich fühle
ich mich viel sicherer wenn ich im bus
sitze in der bahn oder selber im auto
die kontrolle halt habe als wenn ich in
dem flugzeug sitze und wenn da oben die
dann einer sagt guck mal hier unser
triebwerk ist kaputt dann denkst du dir
auch nur ja das ist quasi das
todesurteil weil aus seiner distanz auf
seiner höhe noch irgendwas zu reißen das
ist extrem schwierig deswegen fliege ich
nicht so gerne sondern steige da lieber
auf andere fortbewegungsmittel um weiß
ich hab ich mich vorhin versprochen habe
was die wechsel oder siebte sache angeht
aber jetzt kommt erstmal die siebte
sache und zwar habe ich so ein bisschen
angst davor dass später wenn ich einen
sohn habe oder eine tochter dass die
person halt sagt ja
mein papa der es voll doof oder
irgendwie so also dass ich möchte halt
nicht dass irgendwann später meine
kinder sagen haben mein vater ist mir
peinlich oder mein vater ist voll doof
oder voll voll altmodisch und macht dies
falsch und das falstaff habe ich so ein
bisschen angst ich bin sehr gut
aufgewachsen bei meinen eltern und bin
sehr froh solche eltern zu haben aber
ich möchte halt genauso auch zu meinen
kindern sagen die achte sache ist ich
war mal auf mallorca tauchen und also
nicht so krass tauchen im watt messe ist
wie viel metern tiefe sondern irgendwie
ein bisschen meter waren wir schon unter
mehr unterm meeresspiegel meine ich
nicht unter mehr weil wenn wir unter mir
ist auch egal jedenfalls habe ich da für
mich herausgefunden dass ich überhaupt
nicht ab kann wenn ich fische unter mir
sehe ich weiß nicht wieso das so ist und
tauchen und so war auch mega geil und so
die ganzen korallenriff um fische zu
sehen aber immer als sich geschwommen
und ich quasi unter mg und seda fische
unter mir hat sich ein bisschen komisch
angefühlt also was heißt angefühlt haben
jetzt nicht berührt oder irgendwie sowas
aber ich weiß nicht da hab ich halt so
ein bisschen schiss vor wenn ich taub
oder so dass auf einmal so fischer oder
sondern rauchen oder irgendwie sofort
unter mir ist keine ahnung wieso aber
ist eine sache von der ich mich ein
bisschen fürchte 19 sache von der ich
mich fürchte ist der hass also jetzt
nicht unbedingt auch auf youtube also
auch auf youtube wenn man jetzt
beispielsweise ein neues video hochlädt
ein video was ein bisschen aus der masse
sticht also wenn man jetzt mal nicht
darüber redet über das spiel und nicht
mal dies macht sondern mal was neues
ausprobiert habe ich immer so ein
bisschen angst davor dass da leute
darunter schreiben war voll kacke und so
natürlich ist mein eigenes ding was ich
da mache und so aber auch immer wenn
wenn ich was neues mal ausprobieren und
meine eltern sagen mir dann 8
dann hätte ich jetzt aber mal nicht
gemacht also oder das ist jetzt zwar
kein richtiger hast oder so aber auch
wenn wir dann freunde sagen hey lass das
mal lieber bei mir selber gefällt dann
mach ich es natürlich weiter aber ich
habe immer angst davor dass wir leute
sagen das ist ja kaka also dieser hass
einfach dahinter sache ist eine sache
über die ich mir gerade sehr viele
gedanken gemacht habe wie ich das
richtig verpacken und zwar einfach vor
der technologie ich weiß dass ich
dasselbe alles nutzen das werden jetzt
wahrscheinlich auch viele schreiben hier
angst vor der technologie aber hat ihr
neuen pc und ihre kamera und iphone und
hat alles am start ja ich weiß aber ich
hab halt irgendwie so ein bisschen angst
davor dass das später irgendwann so die
überhand
also das wirklich in unternehmen dann
nur noch maschinen arbeiten und dass der
mensch quasi gar nicht mehr gebraucht
wird
das ist so ein bisschen wie bei robotern
bisher nicht weiß wer den film gesehen
hat der film na ja weil es nicht so
klasse aber so von der grund message er
schon denke ich da so ein bisschen
genauso und zwar einfach so die
technologie übernimmt derzeit so viel
die überhand seine apple watch die
rauskommt und dies und das und es gibt
alles mögliche mittlerweile da habe ich
halt so ein bisschen angst davor dass
das irgendwann quasi so die überhand an
sich reißt zwar sehr unwahrscheinlich
aber das ist halt sind halt sachen die
fürchte also sehr unwahrscheinlich dass
es in meinem leben noch passiert das ist
eben so weit kommt vielleicht kommt
sogar nicht soweit keine ahnung das
waren auf jeden fall zehn sachen von
denen ich so ein bisschen angst habe ich
hoffe ihr respektiert dass das sich
beispielsweise vor der sache oder vor
dieser sache oder vor irgendwann ein
bisschen mich fürchte eventuell fürchtet
ihr euch ja auch vom paar sachen
schreibe es in die kommentare
wollt ihr mehr solcher videos wo ich
euch irgendwas über mich erzählen dann
könnt ihr mir ideen dafür in die
kommentare schreiben oder einfach eine
bewertung lassen und dann sehen wir uns
irgendwann bestimmt noch mal wieder